du changement au début du mois de
juillet à la tête de la gendarmerie des
yvelines une passation de commandement
dans la cour de la préfecture du
département
le colonel sylvain tortelier succède au
colonel loïc barras en poste depuis
trois ans sur le territoire commandé
dans ce magnifique département des
yvelines avec autant de vices diversité
autant de problématiques
ça rend le challenge défi d'autant plus
intéressant du changement ils n'en
veulent pas celui prévu pour réformer le
baccalauréat et le cursus scolaire au
lycée un programme contesté et préparé
par le gouvernement
certains professeurs des yvelines ont
poursuivi leur mobilisation pour
protester contre la réforme de cet
examen
cela à travers une grève des corrections
des copies dans les lycées du
département autres corps de métier autre
mouvement social les sapeurs pompiers
ont commencé une grève nationale
intersyndicale au début de l'été c'est
le cas dans les casernes yvelinoise
plusieurs revendications demande
d'effectifs et de moyens supplémentaires
et amélioration des conditions de
travail durant la période estivale les
pompiers zivi noah ont été plusieurs
fois sollicité notamment sur l' incendie
du siaap à achères le centre de
traitement des eaux usées a été touché
par un incendie le 3 juillet 2019
un site classé seveso aucune victime
humaine à déplorer et le feu a été
rapidement maîtrisé
néanmoins conséquence directe la scène a
connu un épisode de pollution trois
tonnes de poissons morts ont été
repêchés services de l'état élus locaux
associations et riverains s'organisent
autour de réunion pour lancer la
résolution du problème on gère
directement les 6 premiers kilomètres
qui sont la sortie déroger de la tasse
opération et on considère que 99 % de
mortalité sur ces cycles honnêtement
autre incendie il s'est déclaré dans la
soirée du 31 juillet 2010 9 le toit des
halles du marché de maurepas s'est
embrasé un feu d'origine criminelle
un temps installé au square de la marche
les commerçants ont pu se réinstaller à
côté de la structure place riboud au
mois de septembre septembre sonne la
rentrée des classes pour plus de trois
cent cinq mille élèves yvelinois la
première rentrée scolaire pour le
nouveau directeur académique
antoine destrés les nouveautés de ce
début d'année scolaire la mise en oeuvre
de la réforme du baccalauréat pour les
élèves de première
avec notamment la fin des sections s es
et l
tous les
lycée nous ont répondu vendredi vague
même plus c'était plusieurs jours que
voilà les choses se passaient bien
le gouvernement a aussi fait sa rentrée
avec cette priorité la lutte contre les
violences conjugales et les féminicides
des mesures ont été prises
un grenelle de trois mois a été lancé au
tour des associations et des services de
l'état
moi ce que j'ai retenu de ce grenelle
c'est prévention des violences
conjugales
la prise en charge des victimes et
finalement la sanction contre les
auteurs
le développement de la mobilité douce se
poursuit à saint quentin en yvelines la
passerelle piétons cyclistes reliant
plaisir à elancourt a été inauguré une
infrastructure permettant de passer au
dessus de la nationale 12 et de longer
la rd 30
autre signe de ce développement le
lancement de v league au dans
l'agglomération ce service développé par
ile-de-france mobilité permet de louer
des vélos électriques pour 40 euros par
mois le vélo dans le coeur des yvelines
le 28 juillet les coureurs du tour de
france ont pris le départ de la dernière
étape à rambouillet le jeune colombien
et gagnent bernal maillot jaune sur le
dos a remporté cette édition à paris ses
supporters ont fait trembler les rues
rambo liten durant cette fin d'après
midi
l'émotion et la joie de toute une nation
je suis très très heureux c'est l'un des
plus grands jours de m autre émotion
nationale la tristesse de millions de
français suite au décès du cinquième
président de la vème république de 1995
à 2007 jacques chirac c'était un le 26
septembre 2019 à l'âge de 86 ans un
homme politique de droite fondateurs du
rpr
il a été notamment à l'origine de
l'engagement politique du président du
département des yvelines pierre bédier
le 30 septembre a été décrété journée de
deuil national journée des obsèques de
jacques chirac
plusieurs hommages lui ont été rendus à
travers le pays